[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we help you live your best life by
being healthy relationally successful
professionally and peaceful financially
i'm ken coleman ramsey personality
bestselling author host of the ken
coleman show on the rams network joined
by george campbell soon to be a
best-selling author he's here in the
early stages are you manifesting this
manifesto i'm here for it he is ramsey
personality and host of the wildly
popular podcast
uh bar future and uh well that's the
documentary the fine print sorry but you
did the bar future podcast the precursor
so you have two podcasts and then
on top of everything else you are the
host of the entree leadership podcast
one of the great leadership podcasts in
the country so george is keeping himself
busy we are together today you heard us
open we're going to talk about uh your
personal life because it is without a
doubt intertwined with your financial
life and your professional life so
george and i are here together to take
your calls here's how you do it it's
toll free number number triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight
eight two five
five two two five let's go sarah is up
first in philadelphia pennsylvania sarah
how can we
help hi yes i have a question about
refinancing spit loans
i was
curious to know if
um
getting a lower monthly payment or
less time or less interest would be the
best situation for uh refinancing
student loans okay well it's an option
let's uh talk through the numbers here
how much student loans do you have and
what's the current interest rate
i have
a hundred and sixteen thousand dollars
in
a private student loan
and the interest rate right now is four
point
three
okay
have you looked into refinancing to see
what your options would be and what the
new interest rate would be
um yes it
my options would be
two percent um two percent okay so it
would go down to two percent
all right and would it extend the length
of your payments
it would um so right now
um i'm looking at 2040 for this current
so it would be um 20 45. yikes who would
you reach out to
um
i reached out to
um a
company called gradfen and they just
looked through the market for me okay i
would reach out try reaching out to our
friends at splash financial
because here's what i want you to do i
want you to not have to pay
to make this refinance happen and i'd
like you to obviously lower the interest
rate but i don't want to extend the
repayment period because this is how
they do it they go well we'll give you a
lower interest rate but you're going to
pay those student loans for five extra
years and the interest is going to
accrue and so i love that it's a lower
interest rate you're cutting that in
half which is going to help as you
attack these student loans you're going
to feel the progress of that but i do
think we want to do some more homework
here and make sure that we get the best
bang for our buck with this refinance
situation but yes at this point i would
do it if it cost you nothing and if you
can get a shorter repayment term lower
interest rate all of those are good
things so reach out to splash financial
see what they say and then pursue it but
remember refinancing you're just moving
the debt around so we want to attack the
student loan debt attack the behavior
but the refinancing can help as part of
the process thanks for the call george
let's talk just for a moment here
because this is a call we get on a
regular basis yeah there's a trap here
and you you really specialize in helping
people kind of avoid some traps yes
because there's an emotional
appeal
that she has been somebody to share that
with her what's the emotional trap that
we got to be careful because as you're
you're saying
if you're not careful you're going to
pay to just move from one pile to
another pile exactly the emotional the
emotional trap is you feel like you did
something when you do something you know
debt consolidation is in progress right
you take all these debts and you put
them in one big pile and you feel like
wow all right we made some progress
there when in reality you just move the
pile around and you still have a pile
and you know i'm not going to say what
pile it is but when it's dead we know
what it is oh and so i want to attack
this i want to attack the behavior but i
do think there is value uh on certain
occasions and we we outline a lot of
this we want you to get a lower interest
rate we don't want the repayment period
to be extended
and we want you to uh with a student
loan refinance you can often do it with
no charge versus a home refinance
there's closing costs you got to look at
you know the analysis of when you're
going to roi on that so i don't think
they're they're always bad but i do
think it's not it's not the shortcut
that you think it is yeah so what i'm
hearing from you george because this is
you this describes you
fastidious oh you get thank you you know
what i'm talking about yeah diving in
here you got to be careful yeah the
devil is in the details that's the word
of the day on the right of the day
fastidious
the graphics team will come see we give
you a little extra we give you practical
advice and a word to impress your
friends ken you always impress me well
thank you george i appreciate that all
right let's go to linda next in akron
ohio linda how can we help
yes uh my question is what to do with
the twenty thousand dollars that i
presently have with my husband in the
checking account
he has cancer he's 80 years old we've
been married 45 years
i am 66 i don't know what to do with the
money and we have extra funds with this
blank suite
every month because we only own our home
hey linda that's what's your friend
linda can you adjust your phone a little
bit we want to try to be able to hear
you a little bit better
let's try something okay is that better
yes thank you okay keep going okay so
you've got 20k in the bank and your
husband has cancer i hate to hear that
i'm so sorry
and i don't know what to do with it
because he's not an investor i used to
help people with investing years ago
didn't do well that way but anyway i
don't know what to do with money at this
point other than deleted the checking
account and my son has encouraged me to
not do that
but i don't know what to do with it and
i don't know where to add to it as every
month we have extra at this point
because we only own the home
so you said you own your home outright
no we still owe on it you owe on the
home okay so do you have any other debt
other than your mortgage
no
okay and do you have an emergency fund
in place or is that 20 000 that's
everything that you have
no we do have uh some emergency funds in
place do you have three to six months
worth
of expenses i would say three
okay
so we've got three months of expenses
and other than that you've got 20 grand
sitting in a checking account and you're
going i feel like there's something
better we could be doing with this
yes because the banks already called and
said because of fraud they didn't feel
we should leave within their suggested
savings
okay
well what's your what's your retirement
look like how much have you guys have
saved for retirement we have nothing
else
no retirement whatsoever
no it's been exhausted over the years
that we've
you've used it in your retirement age
and and with his
health and everything i'm guessing that
just got wiped out
yes and i can't work either
well it sounds like we need to we need
to save this money because you don't
have much to
to live off of if something goes wrong
how are you do you guys have income
still
yes he has a pension and we both have
social security what does that all add
up to
um
i'm thinking it's around thirty eight
hundred dollars a month okay maybe a
little more than that well i want you to
do like around 50 it's around 53 000 for
the year for both 53 000 okay so you're
able to live
i would recommend putting this in a high
yield savings account for right now and
let it grow just a little bit but
connect with a smartvestor pro you got
to start investing this money can grow
if you live another 20 years you could
have a whole bunch of money if you
invest wisely at this point but we're
rooting for you linda sorry to hear
about your husband
hang on the line linda what we're gonna
do is we're gonna have kelly connect you
to one of our smart investor pros and
one of our financial coaches free for us
sorry not the smart investor pro but a
financial coach and have them coach you
up on what you need to do here they can
help them this is the ramsey show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
conversation here on the ramsey show i'm
kid coleman joined by my colleague
george campbell we're here for you the
shower it's a free phone call triple
eight eight two five
five two two five over the last 30 years
ramsay solutions has walked with tens of
thousands of people and their families
to help them overcome financial stress
we found that money stress is just one
of all kinds of ways we experience
stress people struggle with stress
anxiety and loneliness all at the same
time we all have some sort of crazy in
our family
we've all had lies told to us by
well-meaning people or by not so well
meaning people and the list of hurts
just piles up unfortunately you can't
change your past but you can change your
future and here's some good news our
colleague dr john delaney is a new book
called own your past change your future
where he's going to walk you through a
not so complicated approach to
relationships mental health and wellness
through his personal experiences
and his research and education dr dolani
shows
all of us how to transform hurt into
healing and move from hopelessness to
hopeful none hopefulness and dr dolani's
book is available for pre-order today
it's called own your past
change your future it's going to show
you how to deal with all different types
of trauma and how to get connected to a
community and so much more here's why
you need to pre-order today you're going
to get free bonus items including
a one month of free one-on-one therapy
with better help so pre-order your copy
of own your past change your future for
only twenty dollars at
ramseysolutions.com
today all right uh let's go to shade and
shade is joining us in wisconsin shade
how can we help
hi um so i
am trying to dispute some debt
i've called the collections agency and
we negotiated a price
but i'm wondering how
i've i've heard that we can do this but
i was wondering if i should get it how i
would get it in writing before paying or
do i have to pay before
they would take it off the credit report
i would get in writing first because
what you don't want to happen is you pay
it and they go well that's that's not
all of it and you go wait you told me
over the over the phone and there's no
records of it so get it either by snail
mail physical mail or record in an email
and then you can pay that debt what was
the settled amount
uh uh
like 2 200. and what was the original
that you owed
uh
27. okay so they knocked off 500 bucks
if you pay it in full kind of thing
yes okay well two tips here do not give
them access to your checking account
yep and don't send them a personal check
so if you do that and they've agreed on
it i mean make sure you get in writing
first before you pay did they what did
they say just over the phone they said
this
yes um they also just i i said that i
wanted it in writing but they said they
don't do that like it
it's
they just don't do it that i would have
to pay first and then they could send it
i don't like the sound of this i mean
can they not even send you an email
verifying this
uh you know i didn't ask that i can
certainly call them back and be like hey
you know i
i've listened to you guys and i've heard
you
say i talked to my financial advisor and
stuff well you tell them hey i'd love to
give you money but i'm not going to do
it until you send me an email verifying
the amount i'm happy to give you the
money here's the thing they want the
money and so at some point they're going
to budge and go all right here it is in
writing
okay
yeah good work hold firm on that you
know when they say things like oh we
don't do that you go well great i don't
do what you want me to do yeah make sure
you stand up for me two of us advocate
for yourself don't let them bully you
around and it sounds like you've you've
done the hard work already just by
negotiating it which is great so good
for you good work appreciate the call
all right up next is eric in columbia
south carolina eric how can we help
hey guys how are you we are having a
blast what are you doing
i got a question about um well i'm
trying to get out of debt i started um
listening to you guys and dave about a
month ago and my grandfather and my
father are very big fans of you guys
um so i'm trying to follow you know what
they say and also listen to what you and
guys talk on the podcast um
so i paid my credit card off and then
i'm trying to get out of a car loan
and i know the used car market is
obviously hot right now but every time i
go to a different dealership the value
of the car seems to go
backwards instead of forward so my
question is how do i get out of a car
loan that i'm in negative
so you're upside down on this thing
what's the loan amount
uh 48 000 whoa
what kind of car is this it's a truck
it's a audi q7 wow what year
uh 2018
2018 how many miles
uh i think 55 000.
and what did they say they'd give uh
give you for it at the dealership
so we went to
one a little like three weeks ago and it
was at 40
000 was the trade-in offer that they
gave then we went back um
yesterday
and now it's down to 38. well why are we
doing something to another one what
about if it wasn't that's right
to pay the difference
okay but i'm saying what if you didn't
do a trade and what if you just sold it
privately let's say how much could you
get for it
uh probably 45 or so because they're
always going to give you less for the
trade-in amount and so i'm going to do
some some a lot more research have you
checked carvana and vroom and some of
these online companies
uh an element of charge that's i guess
reasonable as carmax he doesn't have to
george cause i've done it right here
talking okay i pulled up uh just a
little search edmonds is one source
there's many sources
in the columbia south carolina area and
you've got a range here you said you
think you've got 55 000 you're not 100
sure uh but we've got one q7 here that's
got 61 000 miles on it 38 990
uh you've got another one at the
let's see
whoa one at 53. it's got 42 000 miles on
it so they're asking 53 4 for this
uh so just doing a quick uh quick survey
here's another one uh
45 000 miles 44 9 so i know it's a
little bit less miles than what you've
got here but i think george is right
private market is what i'd be looking at
yeah how much money do you have
eric
just savings checking
um about
six thousand dollars of everything okay
so you got six grand i just paid yeah
but just paid off uh six thousand
dollars in credit card debt awesome so
you paid off six thousand and you have
six thousand in the bank
correct awesome well that's a great
place to be because you're gonna owe the
difference
if you went and sold it in order to get
out of the loan correct
and so the fact that you have some money
is great so what i'm doing i'm gonna get
top dollar for for that audi and then
with whatever money you need to pay the
difference you pay the difference and
call it a stupid tax and you move on
with your life and then you obviously
need a car so my hope is that right
let's say you can you owe maybe three
grand difference to pay off the loan
well you still have three grand left so
i'm gonna sock away a thousand for the
emergency fund and i'm gonna get
the
junkiest car that is the opposite of the
car you're driving right now
and you're gonna drive that until you
can save up enough money to upgrade to a
four thousand dollar car and you're
gonna sell that one and do the same
thing and eventually you're gonna trade
up it to where you have a decent car and
then one day you're going to have an
amazing car but right now we've got to
focus on getting out of this pile of
debt and get you a fully funded
emergency fund and get you investing so
that you have some control on the future
eric you can do this can't you
yes sir i mean how's that gonna feel to
get that off your shoulders all that
debt even though it's not gonna be fun
how's it gonna feel
it's gonna feel like
everything's off my shoulders come on
man what's your income
uh
eric
000. oh there we go so we can save up
some money and you said that's your only
debt left is the car
i got i just purchased a house so that's
on there too so you got the mortgage but
other than that you're consuming each
other
yes awesome all right man you're going
to be in good shape once we get rid of
this car but do your research i'm
checking everywhere i'm going private
sale on facebook and craigslist and auto
trader checking vroom and carvana seeing
who's going to pay me the most money
and now's the time to do it we are we're
seeing reports of
car manufacturers getting angry at
dealers this was a major headline over
last weekend because car dealers are
selling cars four five six seven
thousand dollars above msrp
and and that's one negative of this kind
of bloated kind of inflation driven
market on auto you know the auto
industry but
we're also seeing high value for used
cars now is the time to do this if
you're upside down now's the time on the
ramsey plan it's a great time to get out
of your car it really is hey thank you
so much for the call eric all right
don't go anywhere you got a question
about your income your your bigger
shovel hey i'm here for you today and
george is going to answer your money
questions appreciate you being with us
don't move
coming up more of the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org
budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm kid
coleman joined by my colleague george
campbell we are here for you this hour
triple eight eight two five
five two two five and joining us in the
lobby of ramsey solutions
is kimberly kimberly you're on the debt
free stage hi how are you great thanks
so i guess you're here to do a debt-free
screen i am all right where are you
coming in from uh we're about an hour
north of philadelphia pennsylvania okay
all right give us the details how much
did you pay off one hundred three
thousand two hundred thirty dollars and
sixty seven cents oh wow that is awesome
how long did that take 34 months 34
months okay and what was your range of
income started at 65 and ended at 73.
okay great and what do you do for a
living i'm a project manager oh nice
uh what industry i was in the automotive
aftermarket for almost seven years and i
just transitioned over to energy
i work for a company that makes
batteries oh great okay well fantastic
uh okay so give us a rundown what was
the 103 thousand dollars worth of debt
i had about 15 600 in a car 1200 on a
cell phone
uh 6600 on a credit card
1700 to my school
uh 2300 on a personal loan fifty
thousand four 400 in student loans and
25 000 in my mortgage yeah so all pretty
normal wait a second wait a second
george she just dropped more m-word the
import you paid off your house i did yay
there she is so all the debt was normal
but now you're super weird because you
don't have a house payment i'm super
weird oh my goodness yes that is amazing
yes
oh
it's hard to believe in myself should
you just you had this whole mess and you
went you know what on top of that we're
gonna get rid of the mortgage too while
we're at it yep yeah lump it all in baby
you were seriously intense yeah so
technically i guess this is really my
second debt free screen because i paid
off all my consumer debt around uh july
of 2020 and then i'm sorry was it one
i think it's 20 20. i'm confused with
all the pandemic um and then i um bought
my house uh about a month and a half
afterwards okay so awesome so yeah you
just are all in going for it that is so
amazing what's the house worth um it's
actually it's a mobile home okay um so
probably what i paid for it i put a
little renovations into it but um it's
really expensive where i live so i had
moved back home with my parents for
about 10 months then the pandemic hit
and it was just
it was nice living with them but it was
too crowded and i was looking at going
and renting an apartment again um and
you know i'd be lucky if i could find
something for fifteen seventeen hundred
dollars for a two bedroom apartment so
um an opportunity came up for me to buy
a mobile home and um i
you know
paid less than 25 000 for it so now you
don't owe a nickel on no i don't know a
nickelodeon all right now tell us what
happened 34 months ago when you look i
mean you just said all right i'm done
with debt
yeah so i was very normal i thought i
had everything under control i was you
know making ends meet and paying all my
bills and my girlfriend suggested at
church that we go to financial peace and
i was like i don't want to pay for that
i'm like it's a hundred dollars like
okay i got to eat or whatever and um
she's like just do it so i did and i
went and it was just eye opening for me
i really
didn't think that it was possible i
figured i was gonna have my student
loans until i was dead um
and i really just hunkered down and got
to it and you know everybody made fun of
me they still do sometimes you know they
think it's crazy i don't have credit
cards really what give me give me an
insult if you can handle re-saying it
what would they say to you um i don't
know it was necessarily an insult but i
know um a friend of mine wanted me to go
out for her birthday and another friend
a different friend was also she's also
on her debt-free journey and they wanted
to go to this really expensive like
fancy restaurant and my other friend who
was on my debt free journey with us we
said okay we'll go but her and i ate
frozen pizzas at home
and then we went to the birthday party
dinner and we ordered like a really
small appetizer and shared it and then
like had like one or two drinks and
we're like all right we're out yeah
so um you know just saying no was really
hard especially with my kids you know
they're like
dave ramsey budget you know so
um so yeah so it was really tough but um
three years it was worth the sacrifice
and um i know i think you guys have some
pictures um like we went to disney in
october and i paid for that 100 percent
in cash wow
how about that yeah there it is isn't
that the best
a debt-free picture in front of the
castle yeah look at that happy moment no
dad came home with you just no debt
that's the way to do it that's awesome
and then um when we were in financial
peace i remember um we had the
plastectomy
session
and i had um i had gotten divorced in
2015 and so a single mom and i was
really concerned about you know what am
i going to do so pretty much anyone that
gave me a credit card i was taking it um
because i was just afraid of the unknown
so you know the bank was like hey 10 000
credit card or you know here's another
one for eight um at one point i think i
had like ninety thousand dollars in open
credit whoa not that it was used it
wasn't you know i didn't rack them up
but i just that was my security net and
my safety and so we had the plastectomy
i cut up 14 credit cards wow which i had
the most in my class i thought that was
like normal apparently i was actually a
little worse
like how many more do you have lady this
is gonna take all night yeah so actually
i brought a picture of that as well so
um they sit on my yeah they sit on my
desk at home um it's just a reminder to
never use them again
wow that's powerful yeah what was the
hardest one to cut up was the one that
was like sentimental to you there
usually is one that you're like
i didn't really have one that was
sentimental um it was just more of like
as soon as they it's all the ones that
already has zero balances those were
super easy for me to cut off um it was
just like getting the you know i just
had the stack and every time i'd pay one
off i'd you know cut that one up add it
to the pile so the one that's sitting on
top that's that's the last one that was
kind of my main one that i used it was
just a pretty generic one but um you
know cash back points so that's right i
need that i need that 25 on the
applied to the bill so what do you say
to people that are watching listening
today and they're going okay i get it
but i don't know if i can do it what's
the key to crossing this finish line
well everybody always says the budget so
i mean obviously that's number one but
um being able to sacrifice and saying no
is probably the
the hardest one and if you can do that
and realize that it's short term um you
know really anything is possible i was
actually telling um kat here that um i
was on the way here last night and there
was a lady in the seat behind me on the
airplane and she said
oh she's just complaining oh i don't
know how i'm gonna pay off my student
loans i don't know how i'm gonna pay for
this i wanna buy a house all this stuff
and i i turned around i said i'm sorry i
don't mean to eavesdrop but have you
heard of dave ramsey
so
um you know i just
listening to everybody's debt-free
screams was just really inspiring to me
and i listen to you guys every day so i
have a nice long commute to work so i
listen in the car
and uh i listed it on one and a half
speed so you guys seem like you're
talking really slow right now but okay
we can speed it up we'll talk really
fast don't do that so who are the guys
you got with you you got your boys with
you today who's over there yep so i have
um my two sons so this is my oldest son
alexander he's 12. and this little guy
here is dexter and he's 10. oh my
goodness and have they been practicing
their screen they don't want to scream
oh i
can you imagine being that cool with
their age ken no i was never that cool
they're they're camera shy yeah i get it
and uh so they they've been following
this journey with you mom and they they
get it they get how big of a deal this
is yes they they will ask sometimes
we're at the store is it in the budget
can we get good so good that's the right
mentality they're gonna be okay and
you've changed your family tree and i'm
sure you've inspired a lot of other
single moms out there who feel this
weight of i've got to do all this on my
own and all this money stuff and i've
got all this debt how am i going to get
through the next week the next month and
you are living proof that it can be done
yes it can be done just sacrifice the
big word you are a hero to do this as a
single mom it's hard enough to do it
with support to do it that way you are
such a hero to us to our audience to
those two handsome young men there all
right we've got two things we want to
give you
because you have earned these gifts one
is a copy of dave's total money makeover
for you to give to somebody else uh like
that lady maybe on the plane maybe
you'll come in contact with the lady on
the plane going back and then of course
you're on your way to being a baby steps
millionaire so dave's latest book number
one best seller baby steps millionaires
we're going to give that to you as well
so
all right you guys ready to do this
they're sort of kinda ready they're cool
but mama is awesome here we go
uh kimberly paid off a hundred three
thousand dollars in 34 months
making 65 to 73 thousand dollars let's
hear your debt free screen
three two one i'm debt free there it is
the boys are happy they just don't want
to show
and i get it i totally can't they were
completely unfazed yeah i love it well
they don't even know it or maybe they do
but the legacy has changed forever yeah
that that mom left for the house and
everything boom
unbelievable she is a hero that is so
great hey she did it you can do it as
well don't move more of the ramsay show
coming right up
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
conversation here on the ramsay show
where we help you win relationally
professionally financially
i'm ken coleman joined by my co-host and
colleague george camel and uh folks i i
george i'm very excited to share this
uh there was a a a
help wanted sign if you will
that went viral uh several days ago okay
and i shared this on the ken coleman
show and uh there's so much goodness in
this and so we wanted to share it here
today uh panda express you've ever been
to pandex oh yeah you like it yeah yeah
i can't eat much there nowadays that i'm
gluten free but it was delicious back
when i could great fast food right right
asian food yeah it's good food okay so
uh panda express for our viewing
audience we're gonna throw this sign up
uh on the screen here for our listening
audience i'm gonna read to you uh off of
the side do we have that guys if we
don't have it oh okay we'll get it up in
a second okay so basically uh this is
this is a particular sign i'm assuming
this is across the country but the the
place this happened was at a panda
express in utah okay and so in the store
they had a sign and uh the the sign was
titled inspiring
better lives
and the job ad called for general
managers assistant managers service and
kitchen team members okay
for the general manager role
the sign listed that the total potential
annual compensation or earnings
at this restaurant would be 69 000 a
year plus a bonus
all right
and then the other post uh advertised a
going rate between 15 to 20 an hour for
the other positions for the assistant
manager salary role it also included
bonuses
and then the ad included we will offer
other benefits uh in including medical
dental insurance paid sick leave
paid vacation and george a 401k company
match wow now that is a really really
nice bundle now the thing went viral
because
a local college professor i'm not going
to use his name because this dude got
lit up
he got lit up on social media because
this is what he tweeted he tweeted a
picture of the sign that we were just
talking about george
and he said my salary as an associate
professor of mathematics at westminster
college three blocks away from this sign
is 61
500
okay
and uh so people just started coming
after him so then he does a follow-up
message which george it's never a good
idea no you don't want to reply that
once the hounds start attacking on
social media it's probably best to just
go quiet he follows up and says i
promise that this tweet is not elitist
but anyway i'm muting because my
mentions are now unusable go hug a local
educator then he goes on to say the
point of the tweet is that professors
make way less than you think they do
that's all well he just got it there's
the sign by the way oh there's the guy
uh i'm not using his name but he got lit
up george yeah and
largely had a little bit of support but
largely people were like hey dude what's
your problem
you're the one that chose to be a
professor this is panda express now a
couple things i don't think the
professor understands the free market
the economy is so panda express and
they're executives they get to decide
and they will decide based on profits
what they believe they can pay to bring
in leadership
but here's one thing i want to say i
want you to get your way in but here's
one thing i wanted to say
what i applaud panda express for
is that they showed a ladder for people
they didn't just post a job
they said inspiring
better lives
now let me tell you something people you
want to be working for a place that
is thinking that they're not just giving
you a paycheck but they're going to help
you in your life
medical insurance dental insurance paid
sick leave and vacation time 401k that
you know to go work at panda express
maybe some people look down at that but
the reality is you can lead as a general
manager as the system manager do very
well yeah there are so many layers in
this tiramisu ken there's a lot going on
here because on one hand this guy is
angry at higher education that's really
what it is he's saying i'm a professor
he has a phd he's thinking i should be
making a lot more than a manager at a
fast food joint
but then that points to a different
issue the way in which we see
work and how we see different industries
we go well the fast food business that
business that's beneath me see that's
the issue and so that's another layer to
this too is he's going well i'm more
important than a guy who's working the
fast food and so what i want is for
people to stop poo pooing any work
because all work has honor and it has
dignity yeah and it brings value to
people and so i think that's a huge
reason why we're not seeing more people
go into trades because there's a stigma
around a lot of this stuff yeah if you
don't go to college you don't get a phd
you're not gonna have a great life and
here we are a guy who can be manager at
panda express with no degree is making
more than a guy with a phd down the road
all the education yeah so there's so
many pieces to this it's hard to just
pinpoint one thing that's wrong with
this picture yeah well i love the story
because i think it highlights the fact
that there is as you said
there is this status that is attached to
certain jobs and the reality is is that
you can go in the trades and make a
whole lot more than that professor and
eventually start your own company in
that trade and then hire other people
and you're an entrepreneur you're a
business owner and i think we got to get
to the point where parents we're
starting to see this play out on social
media and you got to go you know what
if someone loves leading people
they've always loved leading and
coaching you can go into panda express
and coach a whole team and do very very
well and may work yourself up the ladder
you know you and i both know of cat cole
an executive who started out as a
waitress and became an executive of a
conglomerate of restaurants it is
possible still in america to climb the
ladder absolutely and you you do this
work every day helping people understand
the value and the meaning that they have
in their work and that you can make
money doing it regardless of what it is
but a lot of people they either go to a
certain job because of the money and
then they're miserable and they're
calling your show
or they they find something they love
but then they don't know how to make
money doing it and we can help them
navigate that too but what i'm sick of
seeing is all these people going well if
you're not in this industry you know i'm
above that because i have this fancy
degree and so there's a lot of angst
going on here in the professional space
across all generations everyone's upset
about something yeah but what you're
trying to do is go hey let's clear all
this if you're doing something that you
love to do
it's respectable the marketplace values
this and they give you money to do it
there's such honor in that that i think
we need to get back to as a society my
garbage man and the waste disposal
people they're very much valued in my
life yes and the mechanics and the
plumbers and all the people in my
community who do such good work every
single day they're not beneath me i'm
not above them just because of the field
i'm in or the degrees that i have or
don't have and so i think we need to get
back to that where we can all just
respect each other and the fact that we
show up every day and do work that
matters and and you know it's really
true that if you love leading people and
let's say you got laid off during the
pandemic okay
and you've got a bunch of management
experience but you're having a hard time
breaking in
panda express will hire you that fast
but are you willing to swallow whatever
pride may be associated with i think
wait a second i can come in as a general
manager start just below
70 000 and the reality is you have a
chance to move up yeah and uh you know
listen for those of you that are engaged
in this show because of the financial
stress in your life again david said for
years and years and years your number
one wealth building tool is your income
income and right now it's one of the
hottest job markets we've ever had i'm
here to help you over the next couple
hours we'll help you today right now
but one thing i want to offer to people
george a lot of people need permission
to leave
permission to should i quit my job
they're looking they kind of feel like
they should and they're feeling like
could i go backwards financially the
answer is no not if you land a better
paying job the baby steps don't stop for
one second so i want to uh i want to
bring up a free resource we have
at ken coleman dot com ramsay solutions
the big website ken coleman.com search
should i quit my job quiz it's free
takes about three minutes
should i quit my job quiz if you're
looking for that nudge to go should i do
it this is a short little quiz yeah
three minutes 20 questions it's going to
give you a report on where you land and
then we've got a free webinar based on
your result that'll help you make this
decision with confidence and it can help
dispel those fears and the unknowns of
what i do and what happens and people
just need that clarity to step into that
next thing remember we don't want you to
quit and interrupt your income we only
want you to quit to a better gig that
has the money and the meaning you're
looking for to help you get through
those baby steps faster the more income
i bring in the quicker i get that budget
under control that influx of income
allows me to move faster through the
baby steps so
check it out should i quit my job quiz
kencoleman.com or you can go to
ramseysolutions.com and just type in
should i quit my job quiz hey george
good stuff
i'm getting hungry now are you hungry
after all that panda express talk there
it is thanks for joining me hey i want
to thank our team in the booth back
there they do an incredible job
appreciate you all so very much i want
to thank you our audience for joining us
it is all about you it is your show it
is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show it's
where we help you live your best life by
being healthy relationally successful
professionally and peaceful
financially i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague george campbell we are ramsey
personalities and we are your hosts this
hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the phone number to
jump in it's toll free triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
george i know uh we hear from james our
erstwhile and just iconic producer all
the time we have new people listening to
show all the time and if you're brand
new welcome welcome welcome welcome if
you've got a question you're going i
don't know it's it's it's it's a live
show and and all these things that we're
here for you we're going to take good
care of you
we're not here to use you as a prop to
make a point we're here to actually dive
in and guide you and so we're just so
thankful welcome to all the new
listeners that are coming in george i'm
seeing new data every day 61 of
americans uh live in paycheck to
paycheck credit card
uh is rising the the debt is rising it
is it is exploding and so we are here
positioning i just saw we added a
trillion in consumer debt we did it
casually we did and 61 of americans
paycheck to paycheck so
we can help you with that we want to
help you i'm here specifically to help
you on the job side of things if you
feel like you're in a toxic environment
or you've got some choices to make and
we can weigh in together on that we'll
do that remember this
you can't separate your professional
life and your personal life they're just
inextricably tied together your finances
same thing and so if we can help you
make a move right now to make more money
to get promoted we want to do that so
everybody's welcome let's go
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to joshua who is gonna
start us off the shower in fort worth
texas joshua how can we help
hey ken hey george how you doing we are
having a blast what are you doing
uh
working hard trying to get out of debt
there we go
how can we help uh
so we
my wife and i started about 11 months
ago
we we started with just under a hundred
thousand dollars in debt we're down to
about 35 now good for you uh
and i'm trying to
get a bigger shovel a second job to help
uh speed up the process last year i did
uh
six months of
instacart and only made about six grand
extra to throw on the debt so this year
i'm just trying i want to find something
a little better
income wise yeah but
with my situation
uh i can only do remote work right now i
have a two-year-old son and uh i'm his
primary care giver during the day okay
so
okay now is that can you tell me what
the schedule is as to when you um
are not his primary caregiver is that
several nights a week what's the
schedule that you have when you're not
his primary caregiver
so i i work third shift
seven days a week because overtime is
amazing yeah
at a aircraft
plant
and
so i work uh midnight to 6 30 a.m every
every day how much sleep are you getting
before you have to help him
uh
probably about four to five hours a day
and then you're watching him from what
time to what time
uh 7 am to 4 i don't know when my wife
gets home all right that's all i needed
so we really are limited to uh any kind
of remote work during that time
uh where you're watching your son okay
um how much research have you done about
remote jobs some of the best jobs that
you can get working from home
i've looked into data entry
telephone
operations through direct tv stuff like
that i've looked on i've used search
engines like indeed monster usa job
and i keep i keep applying for them but
i'm i'm not hearing back from okay good
all right so we've got it so this is a
different problem than i thought the
good news is you've identified these
jobs that you can do and bring in the
money that you want to bring in
the issue is you're not getting
interviews
correct okay great all right so a couple
of things
you have to stand out from the pile you
a can you imagine how many people are
submitting resumes for all those remote
jobs
absolutely it's a lot and here's what we
know about companies
we saw some data
uh from the bureau of labor uh
statistics
and and they said that over a million
qualified candidates george
um
didn't even get looked at in 2021
because
these companies are using ai artificial
intelligence and it's a software
designed to
you know
funnel if you will
field all of these resume
submissions and so what's happening is
many times you're not even being seen
your resume is not even being seen it's
almost as if you're this nameless
faceless person
that's probably what's happening to you
if you're not getting any interview at
all sometimes it is a simple strategy
like making sure that the job you're
applying for has a job description and
do you have
keywords in that job description so
think of the most
descriptive specific words that the
company is using in the job description
you need to make sure those words are in
your resume do you understand what i'm
saying
yes sir now that's one simple technique
to try the second thing is is i want you
we're gonna i want you to download
kencoleman.com i want you to download my
free resume guide okay it's absolutely
free
it's a pdf it's gonna walk you through
step by step how to make your resume
stand out and it gives you a free
template as well okay i want you she's
actually already done that great so you
need to so now that we're using that the
next step is what really gets us gigs
are connections people
so even though this is a remote job
your goal is to make some connections
through your acquaintances social media
connections and friends
maybe friends and family but you largely
know all the same people they do right
so what we want to do is we want to get
somebody submitting your resume for you
directly to that person so for instance
if you were to go on linkedin
and you found okay i know
this person through this person we have
a mutual connection what you would do is
instead of reaching out directly to the
hiring manager or that person to that
company you reach out to your connection
not on linkedin in real life text email
phone call and you ask them will they do
a real-life connection for you that
person do you understand what i'm saying
yes now listen there's nothing
mind-blowing i just gave you there but
the reality is that's the old-school
human to human connection and that's how
you still win
because if you just keep playing the
automated resume submission game it's
essentially george like playing the
lottery yeah it's going to take a lot of
time to look up on apply for all these
positions whether it's you know customer
service rep online virtual assisting
user experience testing online tutoring
there's a lot of options out there but
it may not be as simple as i'm just
going to apply and hope that i make it
through and then joshua one other thing
that i want to recommend to you you're
in fort worth texas area that's a big
metropolitan area instead of just
applying online and making those
connections you need to go directly into
some of these companies and just kind of
get a lay of the land you know what i
mean and see who do you know and and and
play that personal connection because if
they're just looking for somebody they
can rely on and you tell them your story
now they've got a personal connection to
a real person
i want those relationships those that
that kind of game i explained to you i
want you to try to make it to where you
can see somebody in person and talk to
them let them know who you are even
though it's remote work i think that's
going to get you the breakthrough you're
doing great though that debt-free
journey it's going to be over before you
know it you're crushing it george and i
are proud of you keep it going this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
welcome back to the
ramsey show where we are coming to you
from our ramsay solutions worldwide
headquarters in the nashville area
thrilled to have you with us i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague george
campbell we're here for you this hour
triple eight eight two five
five two two five george it's tax time
oh boy uh i'm doing mine tomorrow
actually are you really yeah we're going
out to lunch after to celebrate no
that's a nice move yeah it's like you
get it done you go celebrate you can't
wait oh it's great well uh for many of
you you've been filing your taxes with
the same software for years but you are
sick and tired of add-on fees is that
you does that sound like me it's you
it's all these folks sick of it sick of
it it's a disgusting feeling yeah and
you've probably seen all these ads on tv
playing like crazy saying it's free to
do your taxes with the big companies but
the reality is it's not free by the time
you realize you don't meet the free
criteria you've put in too much time to
start over somewhere else so you're
paying up we think you deserve better
that's why we're offering ramsey smart
tax so you can file your taxes online
without paying more than you'd expect
ramsey smart tax includes every form you
need with no hidden fees and no
surprises we even have a promo code
right now so you can file your federal
taxes for free
and if you want more priority support
and extended audit protection you can go
with our premium version for just 20
bucks so if you're ready to ditch the
other guys
and their surprising fees and save on
your taxes go to
ramseysolutions.com smart tax that's
ramsey solutions dot com
slash
smart tax all right daniel is up next in
lexington kentucky daniel how can we
help
hey uh how's it going guys we're having
a blast what's going on
uh my dad passed away in october um
didn't leave my mom much money
and he has uh bought some
gold coins uh they're not solid gold
but they're supposed to be some sort of
value beyond the goal that's in them um
and i just want to know if this is
something we should hang on to
or something we should move
well first daniel sorry for your loss
he's in a better place i appreciate it
yeah
george what say you on these gold coins
well i'm getting rid of the gold coins i
mean uh are they sentimental are they
like an heirloom or
no it's uh
it's by one of these companies that
trades a lot on uh.com my dad wanted to
put money in gold and sure the market
was going to dip and gold's going to go
up that sort of thing yeah well we we
never recommend investing in pressure
precious metals so if i'm you i'm going
to i'm going to cash out as much as i
can on these and see you know melt them
down see what it's worth
maybe to a local jeweler or something
like that
and see what your options are in your
area to do that or there are some online
options if you want to look into those
as well
but do you think there's a lot of money
that's that's in these
well we can we can trade them back to
the broker um so they're they're set up
to buy sell and trade okay um any idea
on what you'll get for them through the
broker
so
the last time we spoke back in september
before dad passed away dad was confused
because he saw the price of gold shoot
up he saw a ticker a lot of confusion in
the last few months with him being
around and
um he thinks that they're worth
somewhere around seventy thousand
dollars
yeah and if you're saying if you traded
them back to the broker you could get
upwards of 70 grand
i i don't know um i'm guessing
i don't know i don't know what the mark
is saying with gold since then yeah and
and i know nothing about it george you
know a little bit
i've never invested in gold but i do
know that it has a poor rate of return
especially when you compare it to mutual
funds and but you know what i'm stocks
i'm wondering george should daniel not
he shouldn't limit himself i'm guessing
to just seeing what the broker will give
i'm gonna say it feels a little bit like
maybe they they would give less
uh and maybe you can sell these out in
the open market i would just look into
it yeah find out what your options are
at least and get a second and third
opinion before you make a move here but
absolutely i'm gonna i'm gonna cash
these out and apply it filter it through
the baby steps uh is this gonna be your
money personally or does this go to the
family
it's my mom's um i mean there's
you know there's a
mom you know where the best way or when
she does but um i'm just making sure for
mom if she needs the money for x y z
um you know the house is older the car's
over you know there's things that are
going to need to be done and she's
living off of social social security and
30 of my dad's uh federal pension
wow well i'm gonna i'm gonna help mom
get rid of any debt she has get the
house paid off and invest the rest so
that she can have something to live off
of beyond social security to give her
some dignity in her retirement years for
sure but yeah i'm getting rid of those
gold coins as soon as you figure out
what your options are
yeah okay all right appreciate that
yeah i mean that's a very interesting
situation there you gotta be careful
because the easy route is go to back to
the broker but if you can get more in
the you know in the open market or
whatever you would call that direct
market that's that's a good move i love
doing the research yes sir you do all
right let's go to peter next in dallas
texas peter how can we help
hey fellas how we doing today having a
blast man what's going on with you
good i am calling to find out about
purchasing versus renting fun stuff
uh we've been boaters i grew up on the
mississippi river on several boats over
the course of the year
sold our last month
six eight months ago
and just now
do i want to cut loose of that much
money
again uh you know for the next boat um
or do i just want to go spend a couple
hundred bucks at a time to rent for an
afternoon
um
and what am i
uh directly into your phone for us we
can hear you
all right there we go so what well how
do i calculate buying the bonds in cash
of course versus just going and renting
what i want with numerous lakes around
and that sort of thing what's your
income peter there's a shortage of
options
um but that like guy thing
peter you're going in and out on this
buddy peter you're going in and out
peter i feel like you're on one of those
fun vehicles going through a tunnel are
you you're
right now that's the question based on
the phone quality
all right i tell you what i got the gist
of the question
you know we don't know his debt
situation we don't know his income give
you our parameters for anything with a
motor in it and i don't want it all to
add up to more than 50 percent of your
income so if this boat is gonna be 50
grand and you got the cars and your
income 75 no we're not gonna pay cash
for this boat uh even if you can pay
cash for it i'm gonna rent have a good
time i'm the type who doesn't want to
own all of this stuff and maintain it
and you're paying the doc fees the slip
fee all that kind of stuff putting the
gas in it i'd rather pay someone else to
deal with all that and i pay 200 bucks a
few times a year 300 bucks whatever it
costs and enjoy it but that's just me
well i've heard from a lot of friends
you know and i think it's a well-known
statement i may butcher it a little bit
but it's kind of like one of your
happiest days of your life is the day
you
are two of the happy stays when you buy
the boat when you sell the boat or
something along those lines
bottom line is you gave a great ratio by
which we say okay if
we have no debt and this is the income
to the toy ratio
um that's pretty straightforward and i
agree with you now if he's on the boat
every single weekend and he's got a
great income and he can afford this
thing with cash easily but if he wants
to hassle with it yeah but it sounds
like he said i got rid of the boat six
to eight months ago yeah so who's to say
you're not gonna get rid of this one six
to eight months from now yeah i like the
idea of like you want to take the family
out on the lake is it a pontoon weekend
or are we going to do some jet skis i
like
uh we've done both we've taken the kids
out before we'll go get a couple jet
skis and and and and take the kids out
and go nuts there's times where we've
done the pontoon and you rent it you
know what's great about it there's no
stress yeah other than trying to drive
the thing yep i was almost gonna buy a
kayak one time and i went i go kayaking
twice a year and it costs 25 bucks to
rent the kayak what am i doing going to
buy a hurry and i like to find friends
with boats that is the life hack now
there is this is the kind of stuff that
people come to the ramsey show for why
buy it when you got a friend who's got
it yeah dave ramsey's got a boat he'll
let me take it for a spin every now and
then right no okay no it's a good it's
good no i i i i he will drag you behind
it yeah we've done some lake retreats
before where dave loves to
abuse us
uh on the skis almost this is a fun fact
uh i almost wrecked dave's jet ski you
did this summer is he aware of this uh
you know he was there but i think we
played it cool okay he's i don't think
he's aware of this he's not listening to
the show right now he's fine yeah it's
never held although the next time we're
on the boat with him i will see if i can
get dave to let george drive just
because i want to watch dave's reaction
he might say sure at which point you
would faint under the pressure i will
find a way to destroy that boat in five
seconds well then i don't want to be on
it then so this is that thinking ship
good stuff all right hey don't go
anywhere more of your questions your
calls coming right up this is the ramsey
show
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague and
ramsey personality george campbell we're
here for you this hour taking your calls
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and out in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage
dan and melissa welcome hey thank you
where are you guys in from uh
thomasville north carolina oh is that
the the furniture capital thomasville
high point oh high point is okay we're
right outside of high point ah very nice
okay well welcome welcome welcome all
right so all the way to do your debt
free screen that's correct i love it how
much did you pay off
345 thousand dollars whoa in two years
and six days oh
wow
two years ago couldn't have done it too
even yeah we tried
took an extra week you guys are amazing
that's right all right and what was your
range of income uh 150 000 to 250 000.
whoa
wow what do you guys do for a living i'm
an operations manager and i'm a
cosmetologist and
i've bumped up my
um
i'm so nervous my income with side gigs
i was going to ask that question melissa
went to work that's what jumped that up
so melissa you're responsible for that
100 000 no not quite that much not quite
a lot of it but a lot of good on you
that is fantastic all right so tell us
what kind of debt was this
so we had a little bit of everything uh
obviously had a home equity line
uh we had a beach uh condo that we sold
um also a lowe's
credit card and then uh obviously it's
our mortgage can what yes what the house
the house and everything well we're
looking at weirdos yeah we're pretty
weird that's awesome we don't mind
goodness
oh my word uh so what's the reaction for
you all once the house was paid off what
was different was the grass different
like dave talks about was there
something else what the grass was
definitely different
we were out of our house for furniture
market we rent oh okay so we had to come
home and like take our shoes off
the picture and all that it does feel
different for me
melissa loves writing stuff on paper and
i like the every dollar app so
i'm telling you the for the first month
after not having a mortgage payment
and you set the budget
you're like it's zero there yeah that
that's when it hit and then you get to
go oh where does this money go now this
is fun
that is fun it's a lot of fun oh my
goodness okay so uh
two years six days
what was the what was the inspiration
what was the uh drag what was going on
that made you go all right let's get
serious about this and pay the house off
yeah the inspiration i let melissa start
because she was inspired before me so
once you go so our pastor did a surf uh
series on generosity
and i was like it just hit me i was like
oh my gosh we need to be more generous
and right now we can't
um
so that day we were having the last day
to sign up for fpu
which is the
second time we've taken it at that point
uh we actually saw dave in 1999 live and
wow then life hit and we just totally
didn't do anything so yeah 20 years of
just ish right enormous yeah so
we started fpu and i was just like we
got to get this gone so i think the
second class of fpu i was like i had a
2015 murano
decked out it's so nice and i said we're
selling the car it was so it was paid
for already but actually on our heloc
so we sold that and i now drive a 2006
minivan yeah we pay cash for
dumped the extra on the heloc that's
amazing and how did you react what she
said uh after class two i'm getting rid
of the murano yeah it's uh that was that
was kind of hard for me i think for me
the inspiration um yeah i obviously
wanted to set up financially for my
family my son gage is off to the side
here as well and my daughter dakota
couldn't be here today but i wanted to
set them up financially
but so that was my inspiration but after
going through fpu
and and seeing this and then seeing us
like get rid of things it was motivating
um and and i think teaching the class as
well
uh kind of held us accountable we'll
start our fourth class in two weeks wow
thanks so much for doing that you're
welcome it's it's good for us because
it's a reminder and it keeps us
accountable to stay the course so and
that's helped a lot
you guys are amazing so what's this
house worth
a house roughly about 400 000. oh yeah
no big deal look at that oh our viewing
audience got a picture there that's
beautiful huh how about that that grass
by the way does look phenomenal great
lawn care i must tell you i'm a guy who
likes a good looking lawn and you sir
well done i will applaud that thank you
yeah so what's next for you guys baby
step seven your young family what what
are you dreaming of uh yeah i mean
obviously we're transitioning more empty
nesting that the kids are 22 and 18 so
for us um i really started and did fpu
because we wanted to get to this point
for me as an inspiration george uh one
day i just wanted to be able to just
give our cars away wow so
that was a motivator to get to a point
and we've gone way back in car to get
where we are
so i'm looking forward to melissa's 06
car and my 09 just to give them away so
that's really what's next setting our
kids up for a great future and then just
being outrageously generous just crazy
generous that's what we want to do wow
it's a beautiful vision and an awesome
why to have especially as people of
faith it just drives me crazy that
they're the broke ones they should be
leading the charge with generosity and
these financial principles and you guys
decided you know what we want to be able
to give way more than we are right now
and this debt is holding us back from
having an impact on our community on
this country so i love that it's
incredible so what's the key
uh yeah i think at first for me um
everybody says budget and the one before
said budget that that is really true i
was kicking and screaming
on the budget part because i just
figured i could just out earn
uh everything right just i'm just going
to out earn it but you can't you got to
put it on paper
um you got to make things visual i
brought this this is hilarious my my
wife loves the color
coloring now she this is our mortgage
little guy she stayed in the lines too
she did a great coloring did she create
that whole snake too well i think she
printed it offline online and just made
a print out of it by numbers yeah i love
it but we also did one that was a
debt-free journey with our consumer and
i did draw that one but i couldn't find
it that's amazing so that does keep you
motivated it's on the fridge you see it
yes um you know she was just very
adamant every paycheck she was carving
out i need to color some more i need to
color some more wow and that's what did
it i got to tell you you need the visual
you got to have the budget you've got to
have a big why there you go
and that's what we heard and i want to
just say this uh to melissa i my parents
got me a bob ross coloring book for
christmas as a joke because i used to
love watching bob ross pulled it out the
other night and gave it a gave it a try
there you go not very good i really only
liked coloring the squares yeah yeah
yeah no i know it's it's it's kind of
interesting i thought maybe this will be
fun i lost track your adult coloring
career is not going to happen i love it
so who are your big cheerleaders in this
process
yeah i think for for me obviously our
family or our kids uh
they both have been through fpu uh some
at some points you know gage was like
how can we just stop acting like we're
poor right uh
but uh they've been through it so we've
enjoyed that obviously our parents uh
melissa's parents were huge for us um
i've got a monday morning breakfast uh
group that i meet with those guys have
been phenomenal we talk money we talk a
little bit everything and they're
inspiring uh so friends that we met in
our first fpu class in 19 when we were
taking it again right so fun now are you
currently teaching class or you're
currently off what no march 10th march
10th we'll start starting how fun is
that gonna be to tell them your story
and they know your baby step seven and
all this and we've been where they were
yeah of course what helps yeah yes it's
so inspiring so great all right so gage
is he gonna join us in there
there he is there he is sharp looking
young man there he's a part of this
journey uh hey two things we're gonna
give you real quick and then we'll get
to the stream one total money makeover
from dave his wildly selling book and
that's for you to give to somebody else
and then second his latest book number
one bestseller baby steps millionaires
because that's where you guys are headed
if you're not already there that is so
fantastic all right let's see let's hear
it we've got
dan and melissa and gage from
thomasville north carolina right there
in the high point north carolina area
they paid off 345 thousand dollars in
two years in six days making 150 000 to
250 000 way to go melissa
let's hear your debt free screen ready
three two one
we're dead free
yeah there it is all right very nice
i want to give a shout out to dakota as
well she's not here with them but she
was also a big part of this what a what
a great story and you could just see
george you could see legacy pouring out
of them they are going to make such an
impact
with this debt-free lifestyle
legacy and levity george there you go
that's dad freedom baby you did it he's
a wordsmith folks
hey great stuff don't move more the
ramsay show coming right up
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman and i'm joined in studio by my
co-host today george campbell and we are
here for you it is a free phone call if
you want to jump in triple eight eight
two five
five two two five
100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or pick the wrong color they
will remake your blinds for free you get
free samples free shipping and with the
new promos they run every month you'll
save even more make sure you use the
promo code ramsay to get the best deal
today's question comes from jordan in
texas
i want to make a career change and go
into financial advising currently i'm in
retail management and finishing my
bachelor's degree in finance and
economics if i make this move my income
will go from 115 000 down to 60 000 due
to the lack of certifications my wife
and i are in baby step 6 and could pay
off our home in two years based on our
current income of 225 000 per year my
dream job is to one day become a
certified financial planner does it make
sense to make the move now or wait two
years until i finish school and pay off
our home all right george this is a
career and a money question here and i i
say absolutely it does not make sense to
make this move now
at all
um because you need to finish school and
then there's the additional
certifications you're going to need that
he's outlined here hey be patient yeah
because the certified financial planner
which is the dream job it is not as far
away as you think it will be there when
you do this
the right way and the right way is
they've been so disciplined at this
point to get to baby step six and be
working on that stay the course you're
making really good money
um and you know what i want him to do to
encourage him while he's holding right
on make it i don't want you to make the
move backward financially it's not
necessary what i want him to do is make
some connections start hanging out with
certified financial planners use the
proximity principle it says in order to
do what you want to do fill in a blank
here certified financial planner got to
be around people that are doing that yes
and in that two-year period where he's
finishing school
and they're paying off the house in baby
step six uh he can be making connections
so that when the degree is done uh the
debt is paid off he can go get the
certifications and while he's doing that
he's still making all these connections
he's got two years plus plus plus
whatever it takes to make the
certifications reality to get some great
connections to get the gig yeah and what
i love about that is he's got a paid for
house well now he doesn't have the
pressure of even if the income dips a
little bit as he steps into this field
he's not gonna feel it and so it's not
that far away and uh i love that he's
wanting to move into this field and
especially in the cfp world it's never
too late i got so many friends that have
shifted moved into that career field
they're doing great now but it takes a
while to build you know a book of
business and get on your feet you know
it's just like real estate your first
year is not going to be amazing usually
so i love that he's stepping into this
maybe one day he'll be one of our smart
investor pros helping our fans feel like
he might be so hey cool hold hold hold
hold no need to make that move now but
appreciate the question so very much all
right let's go to andrew now who joins
us on the line in tampa florida andrew
how can we help
hi uh thank you for having me on this
show um so i'll just get right into it i
am a computer engineering student
i graduate this may
so i am currently with my fiance where
sixty thousand dollars in debt with
student loans mostly mine
uh but it looks like in may will have
around a combined income
of a hundred and thirty thousand
so my question to you is because right
now we do not pay rent uh there was a
circumstance where we had to uh move
with our family since there was a death
in the family
so my question is should we rent or
should we take a mortgage because right
now the tampa area
some of the rent prices are a little
inflated
well i'll make this real real simple we
are not going to buy a house right now
and there's a lot of reasons number one
even if you were debt free
i would say still rent for a year
at least when are you guys getting
married uh we're getting married in may
uh may 12th so about three three four
months when i graduate wow so you're
graduating and immediately getting
married
uh we've been together for five years so
uh it's been a it's been a while coming
cool well i'm excited for you guys with
that combined income what i want you to
do is use all the power you can with
that maybe you're even doing freelance
you know computer development software
engineering type stuff to get rid of
these student loans very fast is that
all of the debt you guys will have
combined to 60 grand in student loans
uh she has a little bit in card debt so
it'd be about i say 12k so total about
72k
she currently makes about 65k and i make
29 an hour as an intern so okay um we're
projecting it to be higher when i get
hired by the company okay well if i'm
you guys as soon as you're married
you're back from the honeymoon we're
combining bank accounts we're gonna set
aside a thousand dollars and any other
money we are throwing at the seventy two
thousand dollars in debt using the debt
snowballs we're gonna list them out from
smallest to largest regardless of the
interest rate which i know is hard
because you're a math guy uh computer
whiz but we're going to ignore the
interest rate
in order to see the progress and with
this income i'm hoping you guys can do
this in 12 to 18 months with your income
if you're doing some extra work as well
i want you to set yourself up as fast as
you can with this marriage completely
debt-free and then once you've got the
debt paid off you have a fully funded
emergency fund we're gonna go back to
that thousand fill it up with three to
six months of expenses
then and only then do you even start
thinking about the house and we start
saving up for the down payment in baby
step three b
yes i know that that hurts to hear
doesn't it
yeah we've been wrestling
with it
it was just definitely the down payment
that that we were wrestling about
well i want you to put at least 10 down
20 is ideal or more because you avoid
pmi which again if you're a math guy
that should make you angry that you're
throwing away money towards lenders to
protect them so make that a goal and
listen this is not going to happen in
the next year you're looking at a two
three four year time horizon but man
that patience is going to pay dividends
for the rest of your lives together
instead of putting yourselves in a hole
right now because
you know rent is high in tampa and the
real estate market's crazy it's crazy
everywhere so be patient let this time
earn you some patience and let you save
up for a few years your income is going
to continually go up and you're going to
be in a really great spot a few years
from now and have that financial peace
you know you know dave and i have talked
when i've been on the show a day before
and somebody calls in rent or buy and
you know there's we've talked about the
psychology around renting you know
there's this
it's almost like an urban legend if you
want to call it that we're like renting
is throwing your money away
go get a giant hole of debt because
you're making it count for yourself
there's that school of thought i'm just
curious from millennia i think he's a
young man you know george what is there
anything additional psychology there for
for younger people in this that you
encounter that you've dealt with i think
young people especially the millennial
generation gen z coming up now they're
all feeling this pressure from society
from their parents and their the parents
are saying when i was your age i got a
house for 8 000 in cash what are you
doing you don't have a house yet and so
they feel this pressure like they should
be further along by now and i've worked
too hard to to rent only poor people
rent it's just a myth it's a total lie
there's nothing wrong with renting in
fact there's so many great things about
renting that you don't have to deal with
that you really do as a homeowner
there's hoa fees there's maintenance
there's property taxes the insurance is
more expensive you have to fix
everything you got to replace the hvac
you got to replace the roof and so let
that time be special and let it be a
time where you especially for newlyweds
especially
not the time to be jumping into home
ownership
how to live together and financial
stress yeah it doesn't help that you
don't even know who's going to get the
socks drawer i mean there's you got some
things to figure out as a married couple
it's really true uh before you jump into
home ownership so i always want to tell
all the young young folks out there be
patient don't live your life in this
microwave way of instant gratification
get that delayed gratification live your
life crock pot low and slow and you're
gonna have a delicious financial meal if
you do that yeah i really really think
that's true and you know you kind of
made a joke about the sock drawer but
you know it is hard to learn how to
blend
two
types of experiences that release a
lifestyle yeah you know what i mean so
for instance
different backgrounds different
opportunities yeah so in in in in in the
woman's house well this is the dad did
this my dad always did this and and in
your house you're going well my dad
never did and so there's enough of that
natural kind of bumping into each other
learning how are we going to do life
together yeah and it is hard it really
is hard but this reminds me i want to
gift andrew a year subscription to
ramsay plus oh it's very him and his
fiance i want them to go through
financial peace university together get
access to every dollar plus our premium
budgeting tool so that is our wedding
gift to you andrew i hope you enjoy that
go through it with your wife get on the
same page you'll be in great shape yeah
and you can already tell they're very
sharp sharp young man good things are
ahead love the advice george really good
hey george thanks for hanging out with
me absolutely on this hour i want to
thank our team in the control booth back
there they do so
so good for us each hour making us look
way better than we actually are and
allowing a great experience for you the
listener thank you folks and to our
audience it is all about you it is your
life it is your show it is the ramsay
show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit thermsyshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we help you live your best life by
being healthy relationally successful
professionally and peaceful financially
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
my co-host this hour he is george
campbell
we are here for you triple eight eight
two five five two two five triple eight
eight two five
five two two five if you are
winning at work but your personal life
is falling apart because of money issues
or relationship issues that's going to
eventually affect you at work you flip
that you know things are going great at
home uh maybe money's great but work is
awful
uh you're dragging that home too we want
to help you win in those three key areas
call it a flat tire yeah yeah and uh
they all work together so if we can help
you do that uh we want to do that
georgia we've had some fun and lively
discussion today good good yeah all
right uh let's get it started we're
gonna go to calgary uh in alberta canada
and niven is joining us there neven you
are on the ramsey show how can we help
hi there ken and george glad to be
talking with you both you bet what's up
i'm calling because my wife and i are
planning on starting a small business
and just to give you background i am a
photographer here and i just wanted to
figure out how best to go about
onboarding some people at the ground
stage here for this business and provide
value for them with
not a whole lot of capital to start off
with
not in a position to give off salary and
everything like that but we know that
we're going to need help in starting the
business
especially finding talent and things
like that and so
i was wondering how i can provide value
to somebody that starts off at the very
bottom with us and
go forward with the business okay now i
i appreciate the question and the heart
behind the question but i just got to
know what do you mean by value
are you not able to pay a salary
well i'm not sure it won't it wouldn't
be like a full-time thing to start off
with right we need to really build up a
client base and things like that so um
like i have the people already and
they're
they're willing to work on it you know
and they're part-time and that's all i'm
really looking for do you have the money
to pay them part-time
um
not exactly not until like i want to
keep as low cost as possible and provide
them with
you know
as we get more clients on board to give
them oh maybe it's a commission or
something like that okay so evan listen
you i i listen you you got to treat this
like a self-proprietorship like you are
the business you're the photographer yes
or no
so i am but that's the thing um i'm
actually you know there's only so many
events i can shoot i've learned the
whole thing of marketing getting clients
things like that but when my calendar
gets booked up um
is your calendar booked up now
um it's getting there yeah no no no it's
not if it's getting there it's not
booked up so here back to what i'm
saying yeah i think you're getting i
think you're getting way ahead of
yourself and i love this i it's coming
from a good place
but your calendar needs to be full
okay and is your wife helping you at all
in the business or is it just some
support work
the photography business is you the
photographer i understand setting up
lights and some stuff like that i mean i
know enough i've got some friends that
started it you don't need a whole bunch
of help until your calendar gets
completely booked and you've got a lot
of requests coming in and you're going i
physically can't say yes to this i need
another photographer underneath me so
you don't need to worry about this
problem yet and so
my my question is is what is your wife
doing in the business now besides uh you
who else is doing something
okay sorry i think i should give like an
idea of what the business actually is
because it's not just
me doing photography um it's not just
just that like i was going to oversee a
business of multiple photographers and
advertising them and putting their
portfolios out yeah but you don't have
but you don't i know that's what you
want to do my point is is
you don't even have the business to make
yourself have a full schedule yet
correct
yes but i wouldn't be a photographer in
this business
you would just be running it handling
the different you know gigs and
different photographers
okay i'm sort of confused but but i
understand here here's the deal you
can't
pay somebody
until you've got the business to pay
them so asking people hey are you
willing to come on for part-time hourly
work and if they say yes then that's
what you can do so then you work with
them you go this is what the market
it kind of is bearing in this in this
area in calgary and so we're going to
offer you this part time and then as
your business grows and you can move
them to full time or give them a bump on
the hourly pay then you do that so it's
not how do we do it now before we have
the business how it's it's how do we
scale up but right now you don't have
enough business so if you're going to
launch this new business that's fine but
you can't
you can't start paying and commit to
paying something when you're not getting
income so you just have to wait and be
patient as you get more business in and
you can afford to pay for somebody then
you do it it's pretty straightforward
okay great thank you yeah but don't get
into this at georgia we see this a lot
you know with entrepreneurs they get
very excited and it's awesome to be
excited yeah
but start small grow slow
yeah i worked for a videographer
back in college and he would hire me for
just part-time work and i'd help him you
know second shoot her at a wedding
something like that running a video
camera and i i loved it because i was
getting paid you know 20 25 bucks an
hour as a college student and i thought
i'm rich and he was he was happy because
he was charging you know three thousand
four thousand dollars to shoot this
wedding right and so you've got to build
that into your your profits but he
didn't come to you and say hey i'll do
this for free for exposure yeah i'm
gonna try to find a way to add value to
you listen people aren't gonna come work
for you because you're going to add
value to them no you've got you've got
to be able to pay your people and
photographers you know they're a dime a
dozen here in nashville you can find
them on every corner but if you can find
someone who's hungry for some work and
you're the one doing all the work of
getting the gigs handling the scheduling
working with the clients that's stuff
that creatives generally don't want to
deal with so i think there is a lot of
value in what he's talking about to just
be able to do my craft and i think there
are photographers who would do that but
you've got to start to hire some
part-time people as the books get filled
up and you can't do it and and here's
what i want to talk to i want to speak
to entrepreneurs because we have a lot
of one to is people who want to start a
business and so if we stay here in the
vin's kind of setup he still needs to
finish his he needs to fully book
himself here's why i know he wants to
run a business of photographers but
right now the greatest credibility for
him would be he's full-time he's maxed
out
and then he earns the client because
they know his reputation and he says
i've got another photographer that you
know that's how he begins to build the
business where he's leading other
photographers that makes sense he has to
win on his own
and create demand that he will then
scale up yeah and uh nevin i'll do you a
favor i'll send you a copy of dave's
best-selling book entree leadership so
hang on kelly will pick up and we'll get
your information and send that over to
you but that's going to walk you through
how dave built a business from a card
table in his living room to now hundreds
of millions of dollars in revenue and
serving a lot of people so i want to see
you scale and grow but you got to do it
slow and it's going to take time
probably longer than you want but that
is the smart way to do it and do it at
the speed of cash always yes yes don't
get yourself promising stuff that you
can't deliver on it's okay be patient
this thing's gonna grow and we're really
excited for you thank you for the call
it's a really good call good question be
patient grow slow all right
we gotta do a quick break but we're not
going anywhere don't you go anywhere
either this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
all right folks welcome back to the
ramsey show it's where america is
hanging out to
win financially to win relationally to
win professionally i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague and co-host to
shower george kimmel we're thrilled to
be with you tax season is upon us i know
try not to throw up in your mouth i get
it nobody likes doing their taxes
especially when you realize that big
software companies are up to a scheme
every year these companies lure you in
by saying you can file your taxes for
free and then when you're knee-deep in
the filing process they sucker punch you
with up charges loan offers and credit
card pitches there's a better way to do
it it's called ramsey smart tax it's our
online tax filing software
with ramsey smart tax you get all the
deductions all the forms and every tax
break you deserve but the best part is
the price we're already lower than the
leading competitors and you won't find
hidden fees plus this year we have a
promo code that'll truly make it free to
file your federal taxes did you hear
that george i said it's free if it's
free it's for me oh very nice george i
love it go to ramseysolutions.com
smarttax to get your promo code and file
without the surprises go to
ramseysolutions.com
smart tax all right let's go to columbus
ohio amber joins us there amber how can
we help
yes hi
i just became a single mom and started
working full time i work 40 plus hours
and
about 12 dollars a little over twelve
thousand dollars in debt
and trying to get that paid off within
about two years times because my kids
are gonna start going to school and just
not wanting to have to worry about kind
of that extra burden of them going to
school
extra daycare different things like that
and to see kind of where i could cut
financially or
what i can do to kind of help relieve
some of that stress yeah so i want
george to walk you through uh the
financial piece and then i want to come
in and talk about the income part of
this and see if we can help juice this
process yeah when i hear 12 000 in two
years i hear
i'm not making a lot of money for the
amount of time i'm putting in here so
what's your income
my income right now is about a 45 40 40
to 45 000 a year okay
and what's left at the end of the month
um
not really anything left at the end of
the month okay is that because the kids
is that are you having reigned in doing
a budget and all those kinds of things
are you kind of new to all this
i knew all of it because um with
separating from my husband i was a
stay-at-home mom so we never really had
he had obviously a lot better job than i
did so we never really had to worry
about that so it's all new all at once
and then also um just taking on all the
financial
everything the car payment the um the
rent just everything all i want are you
getting any alimony or child support
i just started child support last month
okay is that included in the 45
or is that no that is not that's
separate okay well i definitely want you
to get on a written plan every month
we've got to start paying attention to
every single dollar coming in giving it
a job giving it a name so it can go to
work for you to pay down this debt
because looking at her on paper i go 12
000 we can clean that up real fast you
can do that with a side job what is the
12 000 in debt um
95 of it is carla okay
and then also a loan for the lawyer how
much uh how much is in the actual car
loan of the 12 000 is it is it 11.5
thousand oh it's nine thousand what's
the car worth do you know
it's not worth more than like five
thousand okay
what kind of car is it
it is a 2012 dodge caravan
okay how many miles on it
a hundred and thirty okay thousand
well i mean this car market i would not
be shocked if it was worth way more than
five thousand just the demand of those
types of vehicles
so i might this might be a way to clean
this up fast because i don't want you
sitting in this for two years and if
there's not a great way to get your
income up uh then we've got to figure
out another solution here so what are
you doing for work
i work at a warehouse with polaris
okay
and is there overtime there because you
said you're working more than 40 hours a
week
yes there is plenty of overtime that's
not
that's why but i don't get to choose
overtime i have to stay there and do
that over time
okay
and then what's the child care situation
when you're at work all day
um my mom watches him right now but i do
pay her obviously not um non-market rate
not market rate okay so that's another
financial
burden on top of everything else yeah
well looking at the numbers i mean 45
plus the child support i feel like this
shouldn't be taking two years and so
what i would want to do is really look
at the numbers on this look at the
budget zero we can trim see where the
money's going to find out how much
margin we can create at the end of each
month to be able to throw this debt
because right now based on the numbers
you told me you're looking at 500 max of
margin per month that you could create
okay and so i want to see that number go
up to can we create a thousand dollars
of margin a month with overtime and i'm
slashing the expenses and we're not
eating out we're not spending online how
can we create fifteen hundred dollars a
month and that's where i start to get
excited and you start to look at the
numbers and feel the progress and you
see the light at the end of the tunnel
you know how much is the car payment we
know what it's worth we know what it's
worth we know what the loan is how much
you pay in in the car payment
350 a month okay
so can you imagine how life would feel
if you didn't have that
it was so amazing because right before i
separated with my husband we were almost
dead free but we needed a second vehicle
so we got another
car loan oh okay good so you've been you
were on this journey before the divorce
yes like we only had his student loan
before
we separated and that was it do you have
any debt do you feel like he's gonna be
he's not going to be a deadbeat he's
going to pay his payments he's
financially secure and despite the pain
of this divorce and whatever's going on
there do you feel like he's going to be
consistent with the child support
payments
i sure hope so because that would help
out a lot
but i'm not holding my breath because i
don't want it to be a source of income
and then it go away and now i'm
out that good for income so i want to
see you what steps can we take because
in the near future and maybe for the
long-term future you're going to be a
full-time working mom and you can do
this and george is right so one of the
things i want to help you do is make
more income what do we need to do to get
you a 55 60 65 70 75 000 your job
what would you do i know you're going
through a lot right now but what would
you do is there something you've
wondered about or something you you
would love to do if you didn't have to
spend time getting qualified and uh you
know spend money as well does anything
pop at the top of your mind
um
in my job right now i did apply for a
couple positions that would um
make that possible to do a huge pay
raise it's just a matter of
the job interviews and seeing if i got
it because it's just a process of what i
have to do well i applaud you for going
after but what would you love to do you
got it got an idea
i honestly have no idea
because that's what i thought but i
didn't love it and
but i stepped out of that so you're
interesting well i want to challenge you
on something i love you don't have to go
back to nursing but i got to tell you if
in the world we're in right now if you
were to jump back into that could jump
into that jump back into that for a
small
period of time to get out of that faster
get that emergency fund fully funded
uh boy i would consider that but here's
the deal george um i don't know what
you're going to give her you may give
her something you may not but i'm going
to give her i want two things i'm going
to give her
amber i want you to take the get clear
career assessment okay it's a 20 to 25
minute online assessment just be honest
with yourself and it's going to fill out
for you a detailed report on what you're
really talented at what work you would
really enjoy and what results you want
to produce and that's going to allow you
to identify a dream job with your
purpose statement it's going to give you
some ideas and i'm going to give you uh
to go along with that the book from
paycheck to purpose my best-selling book
think of the think of the assessment as
a compass that'll help you identify a
mountain that you really want to scale
professionally and then think of the
book as the guide up the mountain i'm
going to give you those two things kelly
will pick up and give those to you but
george has given you some great advice
you can knock this twelve thousand
dollars of debt out pretty quickly by
just getting control of that budget if
we can juice your income and you're
trying right now
use the two tools i'm giving you let's
identify what you really want to do and
why you want to do it and i think that
75 thousand dollar income is extremely
attainable georgia even beyond that
and i'll actually gift you ramsay plus
as well get plugged into the every
dollar plus budgeting tool watch
financial peace university get excited
get plugged into the budget let it work
for you let it give you permission to
spend and you're gonna feel the freedom
soon enough amber can't wait amber we're
sorry you're going through this
heartbreak but those babies need you and
you can do it we believe in you this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague
george campbell we are here for you
taking your
money questions your relationship
questions your work questions all of
those
are about you being your best self and
living your best life and that's why
we're here for you triple eight eight
two five five two two five is the number
triple eight eight two five five two two
five okay one of the big cultural
norms
uh cultural myths is that a college
degree is the best way to success
now that may have been true
based on where culture was 30 years ago
40 years ago it's not true anymore as
education continues to evolve as
technology
evolves
and one of the things i wanted to point
out
george is a recent yahoo news story
that talks about a new report that shows
which colleges offer the best roi so we
have a lot of money uh questions and
calls obviously people are all in with
their money on the show and so roi
standing for return on investment so you
think about how much money you spend
over four years and here's the deal the
data shows us that a lot of kids are
taking five to six years so this is a
let's call it a four to six year spend
on college all right and so just
touching on a few things from the
article
um
the report uh has a calculator uh where
you can go in and you can search 3 300
colleges in the united states
and from this report you see a lot of
technical institutions
science and engineering
type institutions tend to have a greater
roi right because of the explosive
growth in those areas
and you know the the even the entry
level in those areas is is is quite nice
and here's how they came up with it how
they come up with
because i think this is important for
consumers as they're thinking what's the
right school for my kid what's the right
school for me more on that in a second
but this report basically took
the college earnings premium which is
the pay bump that students would get
after graduation or as a result of
graduation
and they divide that number by the cost
of tuition
and then it's going to take into account
a range of other factors like student
debt
to how long it takes to complete it so
what are you racking up in debt how long
does it take to get to the degree as
well as
what are the labor market challenges
that graduates will face to give you an
example of what i'm talking about here
we know
that over 50 percent i think it was
about 52
of college graduates in 2021 took six
months
to find a job in the field they went to
be trained for so this takes into
account that as well yeah uh and so
we're not going to dive into this very
deeply but public institutions via this
report this roi calculator george tended
to do much better the private nonprofit
institute institutions were next and
then the private for-profit institutions
not so good uh-oh so now let me just
call this out because this is a trap
the private for-profit institutions that
did not have a good roi in fact
according to this report just 69 offered
a pri a positive return is and i don't
want to name names and hack anybody off
sure but you know they're out there
they're they're for-profit and they're
big box it's like hey come here we'll
get you trained for continuing education
blah blah blah so be careful i'm looking
at some interesting numbers here on the
calculator
i typed some schools in just to see just
to see my alma mater has a two hundred
thousand dollar positive roi oh very
nice texas tech
dr john dolone's alma mater has a
million dollar roi
typed in harvard university just to see
three million dollar roi and so that's
what they're saying uh it's very
interesting but to look at different
schools and this varies person to person
you know if you get a full ride well
that changes the game versus going
300 000 and let's also understand we are
not endorsing this calculator i want to
be very clear i'm saying it's a very
interesting interesting tool it's an
interesting tool but i think you've got
to take into effect the student loan
nonsense yes and what you're going to
saddle yourself with and i'm just going
to say this to everybody listening and
watching when was the last time you went
to the doctor's office or the dentist
office or you sitting down with your cpa
and before you decided to pay them for
their services did you ask them to show
you their diploma
nobody cares i scan the wall looking at
the frames i know you do george but
you're neurotic nobody else does that uh
no he's we're kidding he doesn't do that
so this is the point
let me just also give you a two-part
question that i'm trying to help parents
grasp
is college
the only way
for your kid to get where they want to
go secondary question is it the best way
if the answer is no to either one of
those please be okay going to the block
party or the golf course or the soccer
game and going hey my kid's going into
trade school
and stop being ashamed of it for crying
out loud um it wears me out the shame
that we've put on community colleges on
trade schools on state schools even and
it's got to stop because it's putting
our kids in chains for 20 years so that
the parents can feel good so they can
brag to their friends about where their
kid went to school yeah it's become
about status folks
don't go for the football team don't go
for the landscaping don't go for the
water slide if you've got to get the
degree
get it
if it's the best way to get where you
want to go do it if it's not
get over yourself and this is a great
pitch for everyone to go watch borrowed
future it's 88 minutes long you've got
to see this sit down with your kids
parents if you don't know how to have
this conversation this documentary can
be a great place to start this is a
world-class documentary we put out late
last year uh it's like five bucks to go
watch this thing you can get on amazon
prime on apple tv at our website
barfuture.com and listen to the podcast
that's a free resource borrowed future
we did eight episodes on that on the
student loan crisis and it was
eye-opening but it just made me go i
want to shake every student go there's
another way well you realize fall for
the training you realize that higher
education has become about their
fortunes not your futures amen so there
you go you should tweet that that's good
yeah i'm working on that one you need to
spread that one folks all right let's go
to michael who joins us in san antonio
texas michael how can we help
so
i'm in a
dilemma right now so i i finished baby
step two last may great last july my
house burned down oh my gosh everything
in it oh no so sorry
so it's been a rough
eight months or so
since then however i'm still stuck with
the option i can
either rebuild a house
i could buy a house i could rent a house
go temporary housing for a while
the reason why it's an issue now is the
insurance company gave me six months
in october
to for temporary housing
for me to rebuild however
the
individuals that i've had assisting me
with architectural plans and whatnot we
have not been able to get anything
confirmed yet so therefore
i don't i haven't even started building
the house and it's going to be a six to
eight month process to build once i
start groundwork and then you're on your
own to pay for housing beyond that six
months
yes sir
so what would happen if you moved and
you didn't rebuild what does that look
like on the insurance side
so the insurance is fine with that but
there is so they've they've already cut
me the check for depreciated value for
the for the home
however if i do not contract to rebuild
i would lose
the option to be able to get the 70 000
roundabout figure for total replacement
costs
oh so you're losing out on 70 grand
or do you pony up and pay for your own
housing and hope this thing gets built
soon sooner rather than later
right that and
uh right uh my mortgage is at right
around sixty seven thousand dollars so
my mortgage company is holding
that amount of money out of the
uh money that was allotted to me for the
depreciated cost so right now i have the
chance of getting
uh 140 thousand dollars around about
if i rebuild
and then still continue on with my 67
000 mortgage or
walk away go buy or rent something
pay off my house hope that i can sell
the land or hold on to it and rebuild
later
well i'm going to get some clarity or
switch builders i'm doing something here
because this guy's not moving the needle
for you so i'm going to get some clear
plans on what this timeline looks like
and if you can do this in six months
eight months i might just pony up and
find my own housing situation and
rebuild
okay that's my take
you can i i think you've uh analyzed
this got to move quickly though i want
some urgency yeah this is an urgent
situation let's let's let's do our
research let's get all of our options
let's make a decision yeah i'm so sorry
though
i i i honestly i'm sitting here trying
to process what he's been through uh to
lose everything in a fire michael uh
thank you for the call
we admire you you've got great strength
and here's the deal
take george's advice move forward make
good solid decisions the best is yet to
be
so sorry for you this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsey show thrilled to have you
with us ken coleman george campbell
joining me here as my co-host this hour
our scripture of the day isaiah 9 verse
2 those who walk in darkness have seen a
great light on those living in spaces of
deepest darkness a light has dawned our
quote today from maya angelou the great
poet if one has courage
nothing can dim the light that shines
from within
all right let's get back to the phones
triple eight eight two five five two two
225 madison wisconsin brandon is there
brandon how can we help
hi guys thanks for taking my call um
i have to refinance my house
after going through a divorce and
i was wondering um i currently owe like
131 000 on it i think it's probably
worth around 220 depending on what the
appraisal comes back at
i was wondering what the
thought is on um
taking some cash out i have to take some
cash out to
um pay off my ex-wife on the equity but
i was wondering what your thoughts are
and taking a little bit more out to pay
off some of my higher credit card um
debt to free up some of that monthly
payment
well brandon i'm so sorry that you're
going through this divorce that's a real
painful thing and
there's there's a lot spinning in your
mind on top of the financial stuff i'm
sure how fresh is this
uh a month
wow
i'm so sorry
well i'll talk through the financials
with you uh you're talking about doing a
cash out refinance
correct and you're saying i've got to
pay her off so part of it is i have to
refinance get her off the mortgage and
give her some of the equity as cash for
her part of it right
correct and then you're saying should i
take out even more and just knock out
the credit card debt
correct
well the answer is a no from me i we we
don't recommend cash out refunds
obviously your situation with the
divorce this is a different situation
but as far as the credit cards i want
you to pay those off separately through
the debt snowball and not roll that into
a big mortgage
because that cash out refi it's turning
your home equity into debt it's going to
keep you in debt for longer and a bigger
loan is going to mean bigger risk
and so i don't like that option for you
how much credit card debt do you have
um well there's there's some credit card
there's some personal loan but a total
of roughly 60 000 okay what's your
income
70 000
all right
and you said some of that is a personal
loan
yeah there's a personal loan for 20 000
and you have 40 in credit cards
roughly yes wow
what was what was spent on the credit
cards what kind of things were we
talking
you name it i
made a lot of decisions with
my heart instead of my head while i was
married so
well i want to change the behavior more
than the math on this and part of that
is saying hey i'm going to cut up these
cards have you cut them up yet
i i haven't used them
for probably a year since okay okay good
but this debt's just been hanging around
and you've been obviously going through
some things
yeah i've been i've been chipping away
at it but there's just so many moving
parts that it's
a slow process until everything was
finalized yeah well my goal for you do
you have any money do you have any
savings
um i have some like a very small amount
um
saved up just until i go through the
refinance process to pay for any um
closing costs and
anything that's associated with lawyer
fees and stuff that are finishing up but
um after that's all done is when i plan
on really kind of hitting the page
hitting the baby steps okay so once you
have that set the thousand dollars aside
set all the debts smallest to largest
start attacking that little one with a
vengeance and maybe that means there's
side jobs involved can you work overtime
at your job what are you doing for work
i'm a paramedic paramedic okay well that
sounds like there could be a lot of work
to be done uh in that arena
there's some overtime available i've
been picking up what i can as long as
it doesn't interfere with my time with
the kids and whatnot sure well most
people that follow these baby steps they
do baby step two they pay off all their
consumer debt in 18 to 24 months and so
if you're not on track to do that with
your salary and the debt numbers we got
to change some things we gotta get rid
of some stuff cut some expenses sell
stuff get the side jobs because more
than that it's just too much of a slog
ken to go through this for two three
four years yeah it really is because you
know
there's the urgency we've heard dave you
know talk about this for very many years
you know this idea of that
gazelle intensity you know there's a
cheetah chasing you gotta run you know
it's like that's why to stretch it out
over a long period of time it's very
difficult for anybody
uh and so the intensity while it's
painful
it is more productive yeah
thanks for the call brandon absolutely
let's go to margaret who joins us in
plantation florida margaret how can we
help
what happened there i got spooked
i'm so sorry i was just finishing up
grocery shopping i am so sorry you're
you're working well all right that's all
right hope you got some bargains how can
we help
yes um like i was telling your
representative i am so happy to know
that after i followed dave ramsey's um
suggestion of the baby step
we have gotten everything done the only
thing we're at right now is to um
invest
so you've got a fully funded emergency
fund and you're completely out of
consumer debt
yes awesome way to go mark yeah way to
go that's a big deal
yes yes and i'm so grateful to um dave
everything you said it works my husband
he's been with the company
for
17 years now he's a truck driver
he makes decent money and he's having a
company match
but it goes up to eight percent
and we're fully funded with that but now
i don't know where to go with the
rest of it to make it up to the 15
okay are you working as well outside the
home
yes i took on another job so that i
could help get rid of the debt awesome
and you're still going to continue that
yeah so what's your household income
with my husband and myself 82 000
because we just did our taxes awesome
okay very cool so if you take 82 when
you say hey we're going to invest 15
that's going to be 12
300
so if we start with the match you're
saying we're gonna we're gonna do eight
percent of my husband's salary in that
401k because they match it uh beyond
that do you know if he has a roth 401k
option or is it traditional
it's traditional because again with um
on mr ramsey's suggestion we did call
and find out because we didn't know
there was a difference
and they said it was traditional okay so
now we're looking into the rock part of
it like he mentioned you know rock paper
scissors so yeah so we yeah that's what
we say is match beats roth beats
traditional so we want to get all the
match we can then we move to all the
roth options we can which that could
mean filling up a roth ira for you guys
which the max is about six grand so that
might get you close already especially
if you're both doing that and then if
we've exhausted the roth options then we
moved to traditional options so a
traditional 401k a traditional ira
so would that get you to the 15
i i'm not sure that's how come i'm
calling the pros because we were trying
to figure it out if that was the
additional loss would get us to the 15
so i'm not sure
well i'm gonna just do this do you have
a 401k at your job
no unfortunately you have no retirement
options
no but you can open a roth ira and you
could fully fund that with your after
tax dollars
yes actually we did get in touch with um
fidelity because we didn't know of any
other um
and they said that is correct everything
dave said was on point um but they said
it's up to six thousand dollars we could
put into there but we said okay that
sounds good but i don't know if that
goes would make it to the fifteen
percent oh it definitely would oh for
sure twelve thousand total is what you
guys need to be putting in twelve three
and so if you get the eight percent
match and then go fully fun to roth ira
for him whatever is left over out of
that fifteen percent if there is any
that's when we go all right we're going
to start filling up the roth ira for you
up to 15 because we want to leave margin
for baby step 5 and 6 filling up that
college fund paying off the house early
then when you're at 7 you can go go wild
invest 25 30 give crazy generously do
all those kinds of things
exactly exactly so i i'm so sorry to
keep asking you the same thing over and
over again so i'm gonna make sure um so
being that my husband is fully matched
at eight percent with the company he has
with a traditional 401k yes um and now
if we do the roth ira correct outside of
that then that would take us to yes the
15 that would definitely take you to 15
especially between the two of you it
would be it'd be even more than that so
that's the way to do it margaret
appreciate the call you guys are doing
great yeah way to go margaret that's a
big deal you guys are on your way to
being baby steps millionaires thank you
so much for the call george campbell
thanks for hanging out fun times ken
always good to be with you my friend big
thanks to our team in the control room
there behind the glass thank you all so
very much and i want to thank you
america this is your show this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermzyshow.com
[Music]
you